[Applause]
it is right before Christmas and
everybody is getting ready for that big
sleigh ride on the night of the 24th
Christmas Eve see all these toys are
made by these elves these elves have
that certain knack for toy making all
except for this this one
Misfit
Herby aren't you finished painting that
yet there's a pile up a mile behind you
what's eating you boy well see that's
the problem I guess what I just don't
like being a boy well if that's
all what you don't like being a boy no
hermy doesn't like being a boy hermy
doesn't like being a boy hermy doesn't
like being a boy hermy doesn't like
being a boy you H shame on you mind
telling me what you do want to be well
sir someday I'd like
[Music]
to
10 minute
break not for
you finish the job or you're
[Music]
fired why is he such a trans fo I can't
stand wearing men's clothes chop my off
with g though then I might fit
in you can't have this conversation
everywhere without fear retribution and
you see you know that because you you're
experimenting with it by talking to
people so what you're saying is so for
all this time that this has been correct
now this short amount of time
everybody's got to change on the dime
yeah and and and come to the other side
that's going to be hard yeah that's
going to be hard to change my I'm I'm
I'm a he and a her that's that's it
that's about all I got when was that
term invented body shame yeah that was
invented by fat white
[Music]
women that's real
talk that's real talk right
[Music]
[Applause]
there
[Music]
what I
know glad to be with you and I guess
today we are back we're back here on the
YouTube and why didn't anyone tell me
uh so look uh hit the share button like
because it helps with the YouTube
algorithm they want you to think that
we're dead and if at any
point today and by that I mean at a
certain point today with Absol Absolut I
mean there's no doubt certainty yes you
will see
this in which case head on over to
rumble anyway and download the app so
that you get the notifications uh let's
get to the rundown of the show we are
going to be discussing uh well we're
going to do a deep dive today into EV
batteries that's something that a lot of
people maybe don't know a whole lot
about not just not electric vehicles in
general which we know are worse for the
environment long term but specifically
what differentiates them from combustion
engine Vehicles the battery what is
required what goes into that especially
if you're looking at the legislation
right now that is suffocating and
everyone drives their white guilt mobile
so we'll be talking about that Pierce
Morgan is pissed off about Alex Jones
being back on X in our rules for thee
not for me segment and we also have a
this week in Biden which is funny but
also sad so let me ask you this where do
you stand on the issue do you do you
still buy into the idea that electric
vehicles are better for the environment
comment below before we hit this segment
later it's going to be just go with me
go with me because it's going to take a
little little bit of time and a lot of
information and we have the benefit of
being able to do that on a slower news
day so uh this is something that I think
a lot of people need need the references
for as they move forward in life and uh
it's a lot of fun to drive a Tesla yeah
but you're destroying
Gaia number two Captain Morgan how are
you I'm doing well I think it's GA no
you would just
kidding we were talking about
pronunciations earlier Wishful that's
true CU yeah tomorrow by the way we'll
run black and white and the gray issues
in which I went to a barber shop and
just talked talk to you'd be surprised
as to how conservative and of course how
much we have in common but we were
talking before the show I said is it is
it g r a y or g r e y yeah and then we
got the whole conversation color is not
spelled with a u where I was raised in
Canada and it was so just you can
comment is it ay is it ey and this will
give us some Regional insight
and third chair we're glad to have him
we always thank him for his service as
one must and he is going to be at the
Funny Bone in Columbus Ohio December
22nd 23rd you can follow him on
Instagram joshin Mr firin how are you
good good I am I want to say that I am
gayer than Gerald yes well come on now
that's not true that's not true that's
not true we got the sound bites I'm more
geost strata than all of you yeah I I uh
I was jealous you went to that barber
shop I wanted to get a nice lineup they
offered me to do a f they're like no man
we got we get you like a high fade it'll
change your life want me to leave here
looking like house party
yeah come on man live a little you know
well you know what the funny thing is
people are just of course I'm sure that
most of most of the people of color
black people vote Democrat this country
but boy boy boy do you realize that they
are not the modern Progressive wing of
the Democrat Party and that was my
suspicion we continue to do these and
you know what you also leave feeling
better having had these conversations so
uh we have a few of them there in the
hopper including with two black women
surprisingly right-wing really yeah on
every front I think a lot of black
people don't know they're right-wing yes
yes they don't I mean she was supportive
of teachers having firearms who have
Concealed Carry Permits uh she was
supportive of school choice uh and then
she even asked me you guys will see she
even asked me about what do you think
though about like people coming in the
country who don't speak English I'm like
why
dois the fact that you have to whisper
right now you to choose your words
carefully didn't you she goes yeah I
said that's what white people have to do
with everything so just remember that
you should have said look at my goatee
lady what do you think she would correct
you and say it's a f Man chew B
baby all right so uh we have other
things to uh to discuss here today yeah
you got to adjust your headphones there
because they were you you can adjust
them you feel better now you're now
you're you feel put me on the spot yeah
a little bit no I know they're so
sensitive yeah I just wanted to hear
your I wanted to hear you guys a little
more thanks Josh okay Gerald I'm going
to put it back
down come on you'd rather be back in the
trenches all right so from impersonating
a little girl to rewriting history and
inventing new numbers that aren't uh
aren't they're not things former Vice
President Biden has had a pretty busy
week so let's just go straight to this
week in Biden wa if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're for me or
Trump and you ain't black we're at three
national monuments grand
staircase and bear ear Bear's ears and
by the way you know how that happened I
was in a plane a little girl came up to
me she said Mr
President can you take care of be ear
and I I said I thought she said can I
take care of her
ears I said what honey she said beers is
it's really important and guess what she
was dead right and we did take care of
it it's been 65 years since the
deadliest day of the Jewish people since
the Holocaust 65 years on my watch
instead of infrastructure week America
is having infrastructure
decades
decades over a billion 300 million
trillion $300 million if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or Trump and you ain't black guys
come on let's be to be fair we don't
want I don't want to pile on the guy the
Bears ears thing it's a
classic Mr
President every day taking care
of
everyo all
right so here's something else I don't
ever want to hear him say president
again president Mr presid that was so
creepy oh my gosh there 50 Shades of
Gray talk for him unfortunately this
Administration also refused to invite
families of American hostages who were
kidnapped by Hamas to the White House
Hanukkah reception this is a Hanukkah
reception that the White House is
hosting tonight uh to celebrate the
fifth night of Hanukkah hosted by the
president uh and the first lady and what
one of the family members of the
families that uh have their family
members that are missing in Gaza still
believ to have been abducted by Hamas on
October 7th uh they told me that they
had reached out to the White House uh
because several of the families were in
town this week had asked for an
invitation to this event uh but that
they ultimately did not get invited now
despite this former Vice President Biden
he he did uh discuss his efforts touted
them I guess he likes to tout his
efforts to free the hostages this comes
from CNN uh he said that he spent
probably up to 20 hours working on
it oh jeez so you spent Jack you spent
the equivalent of when we have an
evening live live stream one day of
work but he's on it up to and not
limited to 20 including 20
hours what am I a machine probably
didn't actually spend 20 hours he spent
like 15 and he's like but up two come on
maybe right you never wor 20 hours I
took a nap I've been in a public service
for a long time we never wor 20 hours
dreamt about it never wor 20
hours he he just made up a number he
just made up a number he knows he's
going to work 20 hours anything he
didn't even consider the fact that it's
not that
impressive I work 20 hours 200 200 20
hours that's almost half of the
requirement for a job to be consider
full-time he doesn't know what a full
work week 20 hours over two
months he spent less time on it than if
he were doing 7 Minute Hamas hostage abs
two months 20
hours dude there's there's more than 20
hours a port on his son's
laptop that's just with his
niece you know come hold on a second can
we just also it's bother me can we bring
up that earlier clip about the 65 years
the holoc do you have it okay bring this
back up it's been 65 years since the
deadliest day of the Jewish people since
the Holocaust
so 65 cents the deadliest day that means
that Biden's been working on the problem
for years
[Music]
and that works out to 3 billion trillion
Jews saved that's a lot or
killed that's a lot we which weighs 20
hours tilts in the 65
years
65 days Mr President 65 days watching on
YouTube H don't to rumble hit the like
button any of the if this is just it's
embarrassing all right I feel bad for
him the worst wife ever is Jill Biden
yes Jo Biden is the worst wife ever it's
your job when that guy is around he's
gone round the bend help him out yeah
well there was that one lady that
drowned like three of her kids but that
was pretty
bad no no no Jill B still worse I think
she was I think she was unmarried though
yeah okay so there you go yeah trying to
catch me terrible mom not yeah exactly
Joe pen where are you help him he's
embarrassing himself do you think she
loves it like she's like oh this is for
all those Affairs you force women to
have with you look you look like an
idiot you took a dump on the Pope's
floor you
that was a good year I get the
sense that she's like she's she's one of
those ladies Camp David she's not just
like I'm not having a martini lunch I'm
having two oh boy and uh just do you
think cabana boys when they're shooting
him up with me fetamines you think she's
like hey yeah let me get one of them
things yeah bring it over let me get one
of them things and we talk to one of
these interns her Coke she has a Cabana
Boy madmax blood
bag just so that she can feel
alive can you put some 44 yearold woman
blood in me yes
exactly give me some of that fresh
menopause blood that's what she said
she looks significantly younger than him
too yeah of course she does which is his
thing also every black guy looks
significantly younger than me I found
out yeah dude it's not until you see
those gray hairs in their beard you're
like wait a second wait a second you're
over 50 D you're not 30 I'm
72 wow you still can dunk bro so still
got hops all right hops this brings us
to Pierce Morgan who I look and let me
ask you what your opinion is on Pierce
Morgan I'm not a fan I know that now
he's trying to Rebrand himself as this
you know Free Speech Advocate by hosting
a bunch of different people but when
push when push comes to sh he really
does show his true colors when puss
comes to I'm sorry when Boy comes
to being a red
Co I do not talk with the red coat
because they hate my country so he's a
red coat he's a red coat at heart and
yesterday in an article at the New York
Post Pierce Morgan uh was whining about
Elon Musk letting Al Jones back on X and
if you're on YouTube you didn't see us
yesterday we had Alex Jones here on this
show and uh we're really happy really
proud of the fact that you know mug Club
you guys helped rep platform them and if
you want to continue this you know you
have this Nashville Manifesto Alex Jones
being replat none of this happens
without your support lit.com mug club
and you get a free copy of beautiful
differences my children's book uh that
uh we have you know tens of thousands of
printings once they're gone they're gone
between now and Christmas that's it okay
Pierce Morgan go ahead
lump lumpy
pillows so the title is uh Elon Musk
couldn't have been more wrong about Alex
Jones he's not a free speech hero he's a
hate speech monster so that brings us to
this week's installment of rules for
thee not for
[Music]
me all right let's start off with rules
for the so after 30 paragraphs whining
about Alex Jones Pierce concluded his
article uh by saying to Elon I always
love it how these people like write
these open letters I
know certain to read it all you've done
showing by showing this monster Mercy is
reward him for his repellent treatment
of already devastated families
experiencing the same awful grief you
felt when your son died well thank you
for telling him how he should feel
regarding the death of his son you
pompous prick Jesus think about that
like hey you know what that's kind of
one of those things just shut up you
don't get to tell someone that they're
being a hypocrite or or get to determine
how they should behave because of a loss
the ultimate tragedy that I can't even
imagine in their family so that just
that's that's the conclusion but we'll
work backwards this is also the guy
Pierce Morgan who uh I guess you could
say sparred with count danula about this
issue Alex Jones on his show just
yesterday yeah I think he's completely
right in doing it Elon must company so
if he wants Al Jones back on the
platform than he absolutely can is there
a line though on free speech at all for
you for me personally no nothing no I
think that Alex Jones should be able to
go on Twitter if they want him there
then that's fine they can have him there
and he can do you think what he said
about the Sandy Hook massacre was
justified then Justified like he has the
right to say it I don't wouldn't say it
was justified I mean these were
statements which he repeatedly made
which led to actual intimidation
harassment death threats and in the
street going up to these people and
confronting them these parents you think
think all that is fine I don't think
it's fine I never said I said he has a
right to do it does he have a right to
do yeah I agree that someone has a right
you think he has a right to do that yeah
I think he has a right to do it agreeing
that someone has a right to do something
isn't the same as agreeing with what
they say if we saying oh this guy is not
allowed to say his conspiracy theories
or whatever you want to call them
because some crazy guy out there might
do something mental then nobody can talk
about anything at all well you can you
just there are limits to free speeches
or are everything else even First
Amendment America has a number of
limitations to it really okay good name
it Pierce let me guess you're going to
use that old hack argument of yelling
fire in a crowded theater trying to
grift off of the right wing as a free
speech Warrior when you don't understand
the First Amendment and I understand why
you don't understand the First Amendment
because you come from a country that
doesn't have one that's why we left you
don't lose your first amendment rights
even after defamation to be clear you
get charged with defamation or that can
be slam all but you don't lose your
right to speak it it is completely
inalienable he doesn't understand that
and he also Li just to that's not why
Alex Jones was removed from Twitter he
was removed from making fun of Oliver
Darcy a journalist from CNN who could be
mistaken for not saying is an actual
terrorist so that's why he was
removed this idea I mean he spent
something like 16 minutes over the
course of years on Sandy Hook apologized
for it said that it was he screwed up
said he screwed up AP he never called
for violence or called for people to
harass anybody Pier Morgan doesn't
understand what freedom of speech is
which is why when he goes out there and
acts as though he's a platform hosting
people of different points of view it's
a lie it's a lie he's not it's one thing
to you don't have to have Alex Jones on
your show you absolutely do not and I
don't think that that means you're
anti-free speech the problem is when you
are writing in a major
publication you are calling for someone
to be removed based on faulty
information so hit the like button if
you agree with with count danula there
even if you understood maybe 20% of what
he just said well I did love that it was
fun to try to decipher that listen I
like you know get closer to the TV yeah
even though that's not going to help you
hear better I'm not saying it's right
it's not right for example it's not
right for you to be a total prick but
you have the it's not right for you to
do it but you have the right you have
the right to be a jint boy but it
doesn't mean that it's
right can be is it the right and do you
have the right you have the right to be
a bloated piss
bag that doesn't make it right
but and I love his point he said look if
you're worried that some random guy is
going going to go do something crazy
because you talk about something then we
can't talk about anything that's the
natural extension of this he's like if
Alex can't go out and make these
comments he he can be sued fine but he's
not driving people to go do something he
didn't say show up at these people's
doorsteps he didn't say go to their
homes and follow them in their
businesses and make wait a minute I'm
sorry I'm talking like a congresswoman
saying get in their faces in public and
make sure they don't have a comfortable
life so that they can hear it that
that's not what happened with Alex Jones
no and if you extrapolate this out then
there is no speech I'm not talking about
Free Speech there is no speech because
somebody might do something crazy
because they don't like it yeah I never
thought that the voice of reason in a
political talk show would be someone
named count danula who talks like that
count danula I dude it's so awesome look
I'm what of a motor I look at both sides
right like I see one side you're a prick
on the other side you're an
but I can see both arguments to
be
made you got to meet you got to meet in
the
middle agree on ha can me in the middle
like the buttons are between your suit
hanging on for their life clinging
together I can hear you you have the
right doesn't mean it's right now that
brings us here's what's so interesting
is he wants Twitter to not allow Alex
Jones right on the platform okay Twitter
is they benefit from section 230 right
it's treated as a uh as a platform
largely like a public utility they enjoy
those benefits where they're not held
liable for what people say on their
platform as a opposed to a publisher and
just to prove how little he understands
the concept of the First Amendment and
it's rivaled only by his ignorance on
the Second Amendment uh this brings us
to uh Pierce Morgan's rules for
me he hosted Alex Jones on his very own
program this year here's a clip you're
never going to get our first amendment
and I'm glad you had to move back to
England to live under your Islamic
takeover when arresting people for being
against
transgenderism
okay all right Alex so other words he
doesn't want someone to like Alex Jones
to be able to speak with a Bullhorn in
the town square right but he which is
it's basically a video version of New
York Post New York Times he wants to
host him hey you actually can be liable
if you're hosting that person that's the
that's you're a publisher you're not a
platform you are not a utility by the
way I was about to say Elon Musk sorry
Pierce Morgan has also hosted
Sahel Shaheen the Taliban spokesperson
gez waa and islamist extremist leader
Jeremy Corbin the anti-semitic labor
party leader uh Lorenzo Gillard the
Kansas City Strangler murdered 13 women
I like how we say the as though there
are multiple and we have to distinguish
Kanas City stranglers no no no this
isn't the fake you know Johnny C lately
Kansas City Strangler it's the like a
football player telling their college
the Ohio state right exactly I was the
murderer this guy just just wants to
Pedal in smut this guy just want he
wants to have all of the clicks all of
the clickbait all all of the eyeballs
and ears while just claiming that he's
being a neutral Observer as he offers
his platform as a publisher as he offers
his private I'm using the term platform
there's platform and publisher he's a
publisher and he's availing his audience
to these people so that he can hopefully
you know take another stab at relevancy
after the lowest rated show on CNN after
Larry King which is an accomplishment
but those ratings
so why is he so upset that musk is
letting Alex Jones uh back on to X I'd
love to hear from you you can comment
below I have a theory and it could be
that he's scared Alex might drop some
more truth bombs and hot takes like this
and I'm here to tell you 1776 will
commence again if you try to take our
Firearms doesn't matter how many limings
you get out there on the street begging
for them to have their guns taken we
will not relinquish them do you
understand that's why you're going to
fail and the establishment knows no
matter how much propaganda the Republic
will rise again when you attempt to take
our guns I already said earlier Eng has
a lot lower gun crime rate because you
took all the guns exact but you've got
hordes of people burning down cities and
beating old women's Brains out every day
let's try again how many gun murders
were there oh you going to ban your fist
now in Britain last year uh how many uh
chimpanzees can dance on the head of a
pin
I need to know the
answer listen Alex I'm not going to play
into your trick
questions three everybody knows it's
four yes I can answer how many monkeys
jumping on a
bed one fell off and bummed his head yes
I wish you that's the problem with
American Healthcare isn't
it because see that monkey would have to
go to his insurance company just just
Pierce stop I'm sorry fraud fraud fraud
fraud there we
go I cut you off Josh what were you
about to say said he should have asked
him how many licks it takes to get to
the
center well it depends on the owl you
ask I'm friends with the owl I was with
was the spotted owl we don't ban the owl
gosh let's not talk about the the
Brewing owl the ground owl but I didn't
say it hey I need to mention this it's
still the 12 Days of Christmas yeah at
crowers shop.com and we are announcing
uh I guess we have the winner right now
the winner of the 75 in Samsung Crystal
UHD 4K TV is Heather Cahill from Midwest
City Oklahoma ah nice I think it's
kahill but you know and yeah starting
starting today what did I say kahill
what is it Cil to fish I'm sorry kahill
kahill all right I think it's kle
Heather kahill I don't know we starting
today I guess every purchase of crter
shop.com gets you entered to win a
PS5 that's the most current iteration I
hope yes it is it would be a really lame
12 Days of Christmas to give out the
third one back you get a GameCube yeah
or maybe that's retro now it's not cool
it was never cool that's it was always
the worst no I'd be stoked for a
GameCube well you yeah yeah what the
he'd be stoked for half a half an eaten
can of sweet potatoes so we can't use
him as
a that's day 13 true story true story
all right uh anything else no okay let's
go into this EV battery Deep dive I
guess as people call we used to call
these meat segments and everyone's say
deep dive like let's unpack this I don't
need to unpack this pretentious
all all of the references are available
at lc.com we'll have the link in the
description so that you can go through
all of these sources I think that's
important uh for you and again my
question earlier is how much do you know
about EV batteries what is required uh
to process them manufacture them what
goes into them and I think that there
are a lot of if you've driven some like
Teslas they're cool they're fun to drive
that's a different that's a different
issue and I think that there are a lot
of Teslas out there that are first off
it's it's a more American car than a lot
of American car manufacturers are are
creating cool they're fun the torque is
a lot of fun I also have a realistic
View and understanding that these are
significantly worse for the environment
just to be clear specifically uh when
you get to the issue of batteries so
you've heard at ad nauseum that we all
need to switch to EVS immediately or you
are going to die this is so serious now
we're in the hottest year ever measured
we're seeing these extreme uh climate
related weather events just causing
Havoc all over the world and scientists
who've been spoton and dead right in
their past predictions we've seen it
play out we need to give them careful
attention to what they're saying would
happen if we don't phase out fossil fuel
so we've got to do it by
2035 in the next 15 years we will
eliminate in the state of California the
sales of internal combustion engines oh
battery electric plug-in hybrid electric
fuel cell electric it's electric and
there's no turning back how adults who
are in position of responsibility can be
avoiding responsibility for taking away
those things that are killing people on
a daily basis and and the reality
is that we didn't edit that that
actually happened so is any of this true
aside from their electric former Vice
President Biden was right about that are
electric vehicles the savor to humanity
that we believe them to be and we've
already gone through think about Alex uh
not Alex Jones We've already gone
through Al Gore's predictions turns out
some of them are wrong for example
Florida's still
there that's a big one or it's going
strong it's is there something more
nefarious behind the scenes that brings
us to this installment of climate
claims
[Music]
Okay so we've already done some segments
here on electric vehicles right and how
they're powered uh you can go and and
search the channel or probably best to
go to rumble or mug Club wanted to laser
in on a point here the main difference
obviously between supposedly
eco-friendly electric vehicles and other
Eco holoc costing Vehicles is that they
use a battery instead of gas instead of
a combustion engine that's really the
differentiating factor right they both
have frames Windows tires so what makes
the EV better for the environment
allegedly is the battery okay battery
good fossil fuels bad so what goes into
one of those batteries what's needed to
make one all right well let me list the
important raw materials and I know that
there are more but these are sort of the
main ones here lithium Cobalt nickel
graphite manganese also the names of the
Planeteers so how are we supposed to
access all of these so-called uh e
eco-friendly
materials now that looks rough but you
just it's because you don't understand
it so let's go to lithium first uh
lithium very important mineral
especially for Britney Spears 75% of all
lithium is located in the lithium
triangle so that's Chile Argentina
Bolivia and um you know Courtney Love
small intestine now extracting
lithium it's not easy it's not easy
uh the process itself pollutes the
surrounding air water and it consumes a
significant amount of fresh water in the
mining process itself mining companies
also use millions of gallons of fresh
water and in one of the driest places on
Earth locals are scared of what that
will do to their already scarce water
supplies and they worry they won't get
their fair share of the white gold rush
unfolding in their own backyard
so 2.2 million lers of water are needed
to produce one ton of lithium that's 21
million lers just to give you an idea
per day on average 21 million
eco-friendly leaders per
[Music]
day so
considering let assuming that we go
along with a Neo environmentalist
movement okay fine right that we're
running out of water I'm just I'm using
those as the premises here for the
arguments the left is making these
politicians are making to try and force
you uh to um lithium Cobalt batteries
all right this should be pretty
concerning because the largest lithium
mindes they smack dab in the middle of
the desert where water is already hard
to come by which brings us to another
problem where
a lot of the lithium needs to be mined
so another major source of lithium is in
Afghanistan which is some would argue a
distinctly nonco conscious country under
the control of a particularly non-co
conscious
[Music]
Taliban they still get their pump on now
putting n work
in the United States government
estimates that the amount of lithium in
Afghanistan uh could even rival that of
the lithium triangle that we just
mentioned there in South America so
let's be clear here a lot of lithium
comes from remote deserts with no water
uh from a failed State controlled by
radical Warlords who by the way even
worse are rumored they're rumored in
some instances to also be
transphobic no and another little hiccup
here I don't know if you know this uh
they don't build Teslas in Afghanistan
so there's the matter of getting all of
this shipped to a country with
processing and Manufacturing facilities
where you know hopefully they don't burn
people alive in cages because of a
speech
impediment now this brings
us finally to the fact that there isn't
enough lithium to meet the coming demand
so this comes from CNBC again all
references available at L cutter.com
Link in the description the experts are
forecasting by 2025 we will be a 40 to
60,000 ton deficit by 2030 that'll be
768 th000 wow tons of a deficit that
we'll be seeing let's go to another
mineral again we're just talking
batteries here
Cobalt rare mineral it's mined from pits
trenches using tools like shovels pick
pickaxes rebar and of course the process
it involves this toxic dumping it's it's
ruining some landscape soil fertility
water quality killing off fish from some
Rivers that's serve as a major source of
food for local populations now where we
talk about Cobalt most of our Cobalt
resources around 60% according to
estimates are concentrated in mindes in
central Africa specifically the
Democratic Republic of the con Congo now
I need to be clear about something here
using the term Democratic Republic kind
of
loosely because pick one yeah the most
important source of cobalt used in EV
batteries is is actually from a country
uh that has been um democratically
Republic at War for 25
years never give a monkey an AK so
that's just good family fun just saying
sorry here's the war
stuff women and children are doing
socalled artisanal mining but don't be
fooled this is no quaint cottage
industry at barely 10 years old children
lug heavy sacks of cobalt to be washed
in rivers from as early as 4 they can
pick it out of a pile and even those too
young to work spend much of the day
breathing in toxic
[Music]
fumes yeah sorry ran the we had the
wrong clip that's that's my fault that's
so that was another thing remember I
told you earlier that it it was largely
mined with shovels and pickaxes I forgot
to mention you just saw that um yeah
that's also done by children lot of them
of the 250,000 people in the Congo who
mine for Cobalt 40,000 of them are
children let me give you some stats here
their wages are typically less than $2 a
day it's been reported repeatedly that
children working in these mines are
drugged to dull their hunger they're
starved if they don't collect enough
Cobalt they're often beaten and extorted
by soldiers dispatched by the government
but they have weekends off and they are
their own
boss so that's good
[Music]
all right tool man you got your fingers
in the button now okay yes so uh
actually uh there's a company glenor
it's a mining company that provides
Tesla with a lot of the materials they
need including Cobalt they topped the
list for human rights abuses in
2022 think of all the companies that
exist in the
world you're number one yeah well
they're up there they're up there well I
believe they're technically they're not
depending on the list that you use if
it's a pound-for-pound list but you know
the point is they're bad so when you
talk about protesting Gap because of
sweat shops yeah and then you say buy
EVS it's not even clothes because you're
dealing with these Rare Earth minerals
that need to be mined in ways that are
impossible to do without largely for to
meet the demand slave labor of children
luckily Hollywood has picked up a story
and is going to be bringing awareness to
the the masses it's the hard knock life
for us it's the hard life us
okay that was South
African isn't there a new
version where's a chimpanzee with an AK
when you eat
him to be clear people tuning in late it
was an actual chimpanzee with AK yes yes
so now you
know where the material for these EV
batteries right where we we get the
extra material okay but who actually
controls the means of production so if
you get the raw material okay now we
need to go to production all right let
me give you a
hint China China now accounts for over
70% of global EV battery production
capacity and with over 20 years of
consistent commitment to African nations
it is placed itself in the right
position to access the resources needed
to continue this trend leaving the US to
play catchup
so you the CH the Chinese government
just to be clear tiny people but large
Ambitions so it shouldn't be a
surprise that they control 70% of the
production worldwide according to
researchers of lithium production World
70% of the lithium production
worldwide China in 2020 all global
companies to give you an idea some
context here all global companies
combined they acquired about 6.8 million
metric tons of lithium in 2021 Chinese
firms alone acquired
6.4 million metric tons of lithium so
one year 6.8 the whole world next year
6.4 pretty close just
China D well so Chinese Mining and
battery companies they've also invested
about 4.5 billion billion I almost said
million good old days $4.5 billion in
lithium mines in the past two years and
China themselves are behind a lot of
Africa's lithium projects in countries
like Namibia Zimbabwe Mali and China is
on track right now
as well they're on track to get more of
it and by the way they're on the right
track because according to the World
Bank U they report that Global
Production is predicted to rise by
965 for lithium and then about 585 for
Cobalt by 2050 so they've carved out a
stronghold in the African mining Market
the Chinese government in exchange for
development Aid uh and this is
particularly um prevalent it says
something that you see in um in Congo
back in 2008 the Democratic Republic of
Congo struck a big deal with Beijing
China's state-owned firms would build
hospitals and roads in return for
revenues from copper and Cobalt mines 13
years old critics say few of the
promised benefits have materialized
surprise a no China yeah not China they
keep their word yeah not you mean that
China wouldn't be treating Africans well
oh come
on Pinky
Promise let me give you an example 2008
uh there was this infrastructure for
resources swap I guess it uh you like a
I guess kind of like a Chinese gift you
have to call White Elephant now you
can't call it chines Chinese red elepant
in this is
it in this case you know what let's just
call it uh the old China screw
job they acquired a 68% stake in um SEO
mines a copper and Cobalt this joint
venture with Congo's State mining
operation uh I believe it's pronounced
uh jacine jacine I don't know how you
pronounce it but you guys it's a French
word I'm pronouncing but you can correct
me to say it the right wrong way in
English this is according to AP news so
China's also unbelievably active with
their investments in Zimbabwe a country
with huge resources as it relates to
lithium Zimbabwe has been mining lithium
for 60 years and the government
estimates that it's Chinese own bikita
mine located 300 kilm South of the
capital harar has about 11 million
metric tons of lithium resources alone
in Zimbabwe there are more than 80
state-owned Chinese Enterprises which
have amass a total of $10.4 billion in
Investments and contracts in the country
from 2005 to 2020 meanwhile the US has
fallen behind and relations with the
nation have been shaky now I know that
some of you are going to say this next
part is
ethnocentric but it has nothing to do
with the fact that uh you know that
there's these are small Chinese people
and everything to do with the fact that
they employ slave labor and uh you know
as they see their economic Boon there in
China um total disregard for basic human
rights and their domination of these
mineral markets is a big problem for a
place like the United States so in 2022
the United States Imports of lithium ion
batteries climbed up to 630 7,000 tons
that's a 99% increase from 2021 wow how
many dustbusters do you need five and a
Tesla you asked
so currently to give you an idea and
this if you assume that all countries
are equal in the way they treat the
environment now of course statistically
they're
not the United States
relies 100% I know you're thinking 90 no
95 incorrect
100% on Imports and secondary scrap
materials for its Cobalt consumption
China refines 72% of the world's Cobalt
we the United States refines
0% 0% again you have to keep in mind
that that means these products Al aside
from the energy uh the incredibly energy
intensive process to mining them to
process them it has to be sent across
the ocean to the United States because
we refine 0% so the United States for
example we have about one main Cobalt
mind at least that would be of note
stopped Construction in late March 2023
this was an Idaho why this is a news
report to focus on their real passion
whenever people think of Idaho the first
thing they think of is the potato real
cool he's not happy to be
there that one in s sincere and keep in
mind before we even get to transporting
it all of this mineral prod it's this
comes from the country that by that Far
and Away leads the world in CO2
emissions bring get back
[Music]
up R back up the
graph yeah look at that that's China
jeez they're the red one number one
where are you
grandberg jeez I should be in China
right now yeah sure know she would it's
not my job because I'm white yeah they
can't criticize China at all no you
can't criticize China how dare you and
Mandarin like she needs to learn it
probably takes 19 times longer it does
yeah so here's a question I guess that
you probably would have like why would
uh American companies not want to mine
for these precious Commodities all right
a couple of answers here number one and
this is this is also a very important
point because anytime you get to
eco-friendly proposals that's there's
sort of a few issues that you have to
deal with okay is this actually better
for the environment assuming you believe
that the Earth is warming to a
catastrophic degree and that we would be
able to stop it through government
intervention right let's assume you
believe all of those things okay you
have to ask is it actually better for
the environment this being presented as
an alternative is it then you have to
say is it something that is sustainable
and then you have to ask yourselves okay
what would be the rate limiting factor
to getting this accomplished and that's
how you end up for example with
inefficient solar panels being proposed
and wind farms in the United States to
replace what they consider non-renewable
but then they can't actually be built or
installed for example solar panels in
the Mojave Desert due to an endangered
insect because the same
environmentalists prevent you from doing
exactly what it is they told you you
need to do so the first answer here is
regulation the United States does have
vast lithium reserves now we're just not
Cobalt but lithium including huge
amounts in Maine California Nevada so
Maine for example uh the plumbago
mountain has $1.5 billion worth of
lithium ore California the salt and sea
which is one of the creepiest place on
Earth if you ever been there contains
$500
billion potentially of lithium Nevada uh
the mcdermit Caldera that's on the
border with with Oregon it contains $
1.5 trillion doar worth of lithium
that's a lot of lithium
wow
unfortunately environmental concerns and
keep in mind the environmental concerns
that come from the same people who
demand electric vehicles
which is why we have a demand for
lithium and Cobalt in the first place
end up creating regulations that prevent
the United States from ever actually
getting their hands on their own lithium
so United States to give you just a
really quick fact takes 10 years to get
a permit for a m you have any idea how
much carbon dioxide is going to be
released from China in those 10 years
then of course you also have a lot of
local communities who are completely
opposed like there are towns entire
towns in Maine that have passed laws
preventing nearby m due to fear of water
pollution kind of like Ted Kennedy
remember he said we need wind turbines
but not on Cape Cod out in front of my
[Laughter]
house both Biden to his credit and
Donald Trump have tried to onshore some
lithium mining but they have had
incredibly uh diff they've had an uphill
battle to fight so for example the the
the fcker pass mine in Nevada it was
approved by uh then president Trump it's
still tied up in litigation okay so the
first answer is regulation from the the
same people who demand that we use these
as they artificially manipulate the
market to begin with the second uh
answer here is the cost which goes hand
inand with regulation obviously red tape
makes it more expensive but the cost in
the United States is prohibitive largely
because of this legislation so
China they have made it financially
impossible for us to do so at this point
and this is where the idea of global
Enterprises and companies that are too
big to fail who you know get to Curry
favor with governments right
multi-trillion dollar companies end up
creating policies and taking actions
that harm you the American Consumer none
of this to be clear none of this is
dictated by the free market so China has
made it pretty much impossible to do so
so Bryce Crocker the CEO of Australia's
uh javir mining this is a company did I
say is it
jair I don't know is it is it French do
they try and sound French like
ja mining all right sounds like a
cologne uh this company uh they own that
they own that Idaho mine the rights to
that Idaho mine they blamed the
cratering Cobalt prices caused by
developments in China and the Congo so
China controls such a huge portion
basically a monopoly on the production
they can make it impossible for other
countries to enter the market so
considering all this it's really not a
surprise that China is moving to
increase the sale of cheap electric
vehicles in the United States of America
and this presents what you might refer
to you know the Goldilocks problem that
the United States has when it comes to
electric vehicles if the United States
for example wants to rapidly increase
production of electric vehicles can only
do so relying on Chinese Imports but if
the United States move too slowly
lowcost Chinese EVS uh they're going to
make their way like byd is actually oh
that's right we have a clip PD if they
do it if they try and do it fast the
United States they have to do it through
China if they do it slowly they get
devoured by China companies like byd
they're going to flood the US market if
we work grou together to build a
brighter future for
[Music]
today you can make history
tomorrow make
history then he made with a
19-year-old he was on
vacation what else does one does there's
no there's no joke that's just a real
commercial that actually happened yeah
by the guy who said we was taping the
Revenant when he was filming the
Revenant he said we had to go there CU
there was no snow global warming uh-huh
uh-huh is that you and that Chinese EV
advertisement of the irony it's lost on
you and this brings us to the idea let's
let's assume that there was nothing
wrong with the mining of lithium and
Cobalt okay let's assume that the
Chinese government was on us and they
weren't releasing record numbers of uh
of carbon emissions into the air um
let's assume that it then did not have
to be transported to the United States
or anywhere else in the western world
because we have a dependency on
basically a monopoly that is reinforced
by uh International corporations and the
Communist Chinese government let's
assume all of that and still believe
that EV batteries good combustion
engines bad okay that brings us to the
batteries been made sure you know you
break a few child slaves but the
batteries are made that's a good thing
now Jes once the battery is produced how
long does it even last well let's look
at the and again Tesla's cool cars a lot
of fun to drive let's look at the Tesla
Model 3 their warranty actually as an
example 8 years 100,000 miles but the
fine print it allows for 30% degradation
that means the ability to only hold 70%
of its original charge before being
considered defective o at least though
once your battery is dead good news is
you can recycle that's good sorry I
turns out it costs more to recycle a
lithium battery than it is to just mine
more lithium to make a new battery just
toss some Democratic Republic of Congo
bodies at
it should I put this in the blue bin or
the green bin just grab a just throw it
a Zimbabwe Zimbabwe child it's fine it's
just it's the same net result so how do
we how do we find ourselves here and
where does that go about 5% of lithium
batteries are being recycled globally
wow 5% meaning that the majority of them
the vast majority if you do the math 95%
are just sitting around somewhere being
a pollutant no matter what you
try see we're Crea but that's really
more of an arts and corre it's a hobby
it's not it's not stable it's not
sustainable no it'll catch fire as an
alternative it would have went with
Energizer but uh okay fine whatever they
the problem is I like my batteries to to
go ah but I don't want them to keep
going and going I guess you go you
stop limit it's
unnatural so there are entire swats of
EVS that have been abandoned what they
call electric vehicle graveyards in
China it look it's like staring into a
crystal ball because it's all a money
grab and it's a ridiculous scheme and a
Ponzi scheme type situation in China
they just pump these things out without
doing proper market research without
actually seeing if it was viable or not
and so the end result is fields and
Fields of thousands of hundreds of
thousands of abandoned vehicles that are
now going to rot now this is where it
gets Insidious these cars are electric
vehicles I prefer my equally Eco
unfriendly diesel
graveyards that's not really an
important point it just comes down to
personal preference I'm a diesel
graveyard
guy
I'm a people graveyard I'm a
yeah sometimes I drive past a diesel
graveyard I go can I hold my breath no
it's too big what am I pearl
diver so
what's the worst I guess and I yeah I
would say ironic part about the whole EV
charade I'm using it appropriate let not
pull lism said it's all powered by
fossil fuels anyway coal natural gas
petroleum other they count about 60% of
all electricity production in the United
States of America Renewables they're way
too far away from replacing coal other
sources of energy since 2004 the world
has invested $6.7 trillion doll into
this energy transition and what do they
get for the money fossil fuels Still
Supply 84% of the world's energy down a
total of less than
2% since 2004 20 years 2% in that same
time China India doing this on the graph
so
stupid stupid what just
that that's what it's doing got to fix
your hair now to fix sorry that happens
every that happens every time I do the
CO2 emission
graph my favorite characters so let's
let's let's let's bring this home here
and again all of the references are
available uh the link is in the
description lth credit.com I highly
encourage that you go and research this
more because this is uh it's a con it's
a con there nothing by the way I have no
problem if you like electric cars
they're cool I get it they're fun to
drive in some cases they make more sense
in most cases they don't but as it
relates to the environment as it relates
to government stepping in and punishing
you raising the prices of energy that
you need in the name of the environment
it's a lie and they are invariably as
government does
when they intend to solve a problem more
harm than good let's walk through it
okay the ingredients that are required
these minerals Cobalt lithium right now
this of course relies on dirty mining
United States Reliance and authoritarian
owners of Mines the use of child slave
labor and then these batteries rely
entirely on minerals that are procured
through all of these practices that
we've discussed countries run by places
like the Taliban the Communist Chinese
government that use child slave labor to
make inefficient une eco-friendly
Vehicles all so that you can roll down
your suburban Street in your white guilt
[Music]
mobile so someone tries to tell you you
need to go electric they force you to go
electric into a car with a giant lithium
battery by the power of yours combined
he's a dick that's been this in of
climate
claims all right you mean I can't I
can't feel like I'm doing my part what
do you mean by buying an electric
vehicle nope no you can I just I just
won't you can feel a lot of
things that's true I just won't actually
be doing my part yeah so when Elon mus
said he's done more than any human being
on the planet to to help the climate
probably not probably not it depends on
your goals if you want not help the
climate yeah well if you're but also if
you it depends on if you're a uh you
know a child in one of these countries
probably not loving the demand for uh
Cobalt right uh in the mining process
but you know it'll solve the population
problem because a life expectancy isn't
great oh plus according to that video
they can add to the resume artisanal
mining yes they can that's what they
called it they called it artisanal
mining like cottage industry just
buzzwords like it was an Italian BMT
Artis yeah and there's like I wonder if
there's a hierarchy too or someone like
who who mins Mangan is like well I'm
artisanal mining
adjacent gosh one day to be in the
Cobalt mine H I'm stuck in
manganese no one ever thinks about
manganese no I'm like the middle child I
don't
know they
lithium catch fire when it touches air I
me think it's flammable I know you can't
bring it on an airplane uh in a certain
capacity like it touches air it goes on
fire ah yeah yeah don't let the
terrorists know that yeah thanks all you
have to do is blow on it and you get
your
virgins yeah you ever puncture a phone
battery and it starts swelling up it's
cuz it's Lighting on fire ah really good
to know inside the phone yeah that's why
you see phone explode when someone stabs
the battery with like a knife like it
it'll explode I thought I just thought
it was a prank I thought people were
putting blasting caps in phones that was
a thing I didn't know that oops L was
crazy glad I have it in my pocket I feel
bad for the one person out there who
finds like the last remaining blasting
cap yeah on railroads and loses a hand
cuz they don't do the PSAs anymore don't
play with blasting caps but I'm sure
there are a few still around or don't
play with railroads who's out there you
didn't play with a railroad so write a
passage it really is
no ah come on I did come on dude yeah
that was my thing I would do the
little watch here goes the train it's
going to derail yeah that's exactly yeah
you know it happens um that's to busy
tying girls up on them yes exactly and
then saving them
exactly Josh
Whiplash do you want to see a video of a
lithium battery like going up in Flames
do I want to yeah do you have to ask yes
got it
on practice my
stabbing yeah you're exposing it to air
there you
go
who
whoa huh that is cool that can't be
normal that is neat that is normal
really yeah it's in your pocket that's
like like if I have my phone in the
wrong position in my pocket with a bobby
pin I'm going to look like The Rocketeer
the bobby pin punctures the battery in
your phone but I think it'd take a lot
to well the back of the phone is
supposed to be really strong compared to
the front of I mean that guy stabbed it
like four
times you know what I mean it's not no
one's saying it's impenetrable what if
it's like cars and Ben Carson hits that
instead of a belt buckle that's true
there you go then you're going to have
some roasted chestnuts my friend his
mother should thank her lucky stars true
fires are really hard to extinguish
because you basically create a blowtorch
with batteries yeah
yeah so we should be dropping these on
the ter but let's be fair you know a
combustion engine fire is no picnic
either no yeah but you can put it out
either way someone's shouting what a
world what a world what a world a
gasoline either way that receiver from
the Raiders is going to prison
yeah and when he called 911 what did he
say tell my wife I love her EVS are good
what happened to you cell
phone cancer no it's a support group
that going on the circle what happened
to you cordless Dyson back
me how about you LG
zero and you Marlboro yeah yeah what up
it's the wrong room that's room
C7 all right we have uh by the way uh we
have you know every now and then we'll
do these meet segments where it's I get
it's it's it's more of an evergreen but
it's just something that hopefully can
help you have these discussions As you
move forward so many people are fooled
by this and it's not that hard to poke
holes and it's not that hard to dissect
you don't have to be a genius you don't
have to be a climatologist to understand
that the econom ICS don't make sense and
the energy required doesn't make sense
let alone this is where when people say
oh man I look at every issue
individually no no the ism the ideology
does matter because these nations on
whom you are depending they of course
have an ideology and you can't simply
replace it without any semblance of
right or wrong yourself so you need to
look at these issues critically you need
to look at issues individually but I do
think it's important to have a worldview
otherwise you can be led astray by any
of that's the only reason I would say
this if you have to put a finer point on
it the only reason that people are
driving these electric vehicles thinking
they are helping the environment is
because they have no worldview and so
they buy everything Hook Line and Sinker
just like they did with Co so if you're
watching right now uh on Rumble I think
we're still on YouTube if you're on
YouTube head on over to rumble but on
Rumble you click that button below you
can join Mud Club and uh you'll just
continue watching this seamlessly we're
going to do a segment would you rather
right now you get a copy of my
children's book um beautiful differences
not a political book just a love letter
to my children it's a love letter to my
club once they are gone they are gone
and uh hey
good job uh that everyone out there Alex
Jones back on we're going to continue
with our rep platforming and the
Nashville Manifesto we talked about that
yesterday how they concluded their
investigation in Nashville so a lot of
wins for you mug club we really do
appreciate you Rumble thank you very
much we're going to continue on mug Club
but YouTube I haven't said this in a
while a piss
off
[Applause]
[Music]
what